OKAY GOOD MORNING MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE IN THE PUBLIC WELCOME
TO THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT
BEFORE IT BEGAN I'LL TAKE A FEW
MINUTES AGO THREE FEW OPTIONS
AND PROTOCOLS FOR THIS HEARING
TODAY. THE STATE CAPITALS OPEN
THE PUBLIC AND WEARING A MASK IS
NO LONGER REQUIRED. WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THAT MATTHEW WARD ALL
IN ALL COMMON AREAS IN SHARED
SPACES IN THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
IN THIS HEARING. WE ALSO STILL
ENCOURAGE INDIVIDUALS TO
CONTINUE PRACTICING SOCIAL
DISTANCING. FOR THIS HEARING THE
PUBLIC CAN PARTICIPATE IN PERSON
OR ON THE PHONE. FOR THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM IN ROOM FOUR FOUR
FOUR THE STATE CAPITOL WERE
MEETING. IF ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
WANTS TO TESTIFY ON A BILL
UNLESS YOU COME FORWARD AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. DIVIDE YOUR
TESTIMONY BUT PLEASE DO NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. AFTER DONE
SPEAKING YOU CONNECTS THIS ROOM
A RETURN YOUR SEATS. IF YOU
LEAVE THIS ROOM PLEASE LIMIT
ELEVATOR USED TO WHAT IS
DESCRIBED ON THE SCIENCE NEAR
THE ELEVATORS. FOR ILLNESS IS
CALLING ON THE PHONE WE ALSO BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THAT WOULD ASSIST
CONTINUES TO TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
IN THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR YOU'LL
FIND THIS PHONE NUMBER ON THE
BOTTOM OF YOUR TV SCREEN OR
OTHER VIEWING DEVICE. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE DO SO AS YOU
OFFER THE BILL. BEGINS
PRESENTING THE BILL. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. DEPENDING
ON WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
A BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE LUMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE SUCH AS MUTING YOUR TV.
LIVESTREAM BROADCASTS CHILDREN
ANOTHER SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
INTERRUPTION AND SOUND
DISTORTION. IF YOUR MAIN WITNESS
PROVIDING SO SENSITIVE.
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ON A BILL YOUR MAN I
LIVE LINE IT WILL NEED TO MUTE
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU'RE CALLED ON
TO SPEAK SAID EVERYONE IS AWARE
THIS COMMITTEE ACCEPTS WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL OF THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE KNICKERS AS THOSE WHO
HAVE ANY TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES
TO USE THIS OPTION. WE'RE LIVING
TESTIMONY TO PAY FOR PRIMARY
WITNESSES FOR EACH BILL TO TWO
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT INTO
OPPOSITION EACH OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES MAXIMUM TO SPEAK THIRD
LISTEN TO PART ME WITNESSES
REGARDLESS OF POSITION. THE
MAXIMUM TWO MINUTES STILL
APPLIES. AFTER PROMISES ARE DONE
EVERYONE ELSE WILL BE PERMITTED
TO SAY THEIR NAME ORGANIZATION
IF ANY. IMPOSITION OF THE BILL
ONCE AGAIN I SAID NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY IMPOSITION
OF THE BILL. I'LL BE ASKING THE
PHONE OPERATOR TO MOVE ON. TO
THE NEXT BIGGER WHEN YOUR TIME
IS UP. REGARDING INSTRUCTIONS ON
HIS HEARING. THE ASSEMBLY HAS
EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO COMMITTEE AND FOR
PROCEEDINGS LAW LAST FEW YEARS.
SO EVERYONE IS CLEAR. CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR PEAS
OR THE CONDUCT THE HEARING IS
PROHIBITED. TO ADDRESS ANY
DISRUPTIVE. CONDUCT I WOULD
RECKON THE STOCK ONE INDIVIDUAL
THAT THAT THEY CONTINUE THEY
WILL BE REMOVED FROM THE
PARTICIPATING IN THE HEARING.
THIS APPLIES TO IN PERSON AND
FULL PARTICIPATION IF NECESSARY.
MATERNALLY RECESSED THE HEARING.
THANK IN ADVANCE FOR YOUR
COOPERATION. WE WERE. WE WERE.
MR VOEPEL CAN YOU WAIT ONE
SECOND FOR ESTABLISH A QUORUM
PLEASE SIR THIS HEARING WE HAVE
FIVE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA THAT
WILL WORK THROUGH A FILE ORDER
FOR THOSE ARE WONDERING THERE IS
NO SUBSTITUTE FOR THE VACANCY.
FOR THIS HEARING. WE'RE BEGAN
HIS TELEPORT. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. COOPER
HERE. VOEPEL THE OPRAH FOR
PRESIDENT DONALD COOLEY COOLEY
CREDIBLE DONNELL THEATRE HERE
THEY ARE FOCUSING. GOT A QUORUM-
REST. THANK YOU- WE'RE GOING TO
START A TOP ACTUALLY NOT THE
TELEVISION OR TALK WITH MR
COOLEY. FINE. A FOUR STARTING
THIS COOLEY ON ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB TWO FOUR FOUR THREE MR
COOLEY- YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
BILL WHEN YOU READY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR CALLING. IN THIS
MORNING- WHAT ARE THE MARKET CAP
RANGE WE'VE ALL KNOWN FOR SO
MANY YEARS SOLIS LONGER VERY
FINE PERSON SOMEONE'S IN THE
BUILDING LONG TIME IS FOR SORT
OF A DEJA VU EXPERIENCE. BUT THE
VERY. IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
COMMUNITY SO I ACTUALLY FEEL.
IMPELLED TO SAY SOMETHING AS WE
LAUNCH- THANK YOU FOR THAT THANK
YOU MISTER CODE VERY
APPROPRIATE- SO IT'S AN HONOR TO
THEY'D BE HE'D BE HERE BEFORE
THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
AND RETIREMENT COMMITTEE ON
MARCH THIRTIETH. GOOD MORNING
ASSURE MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
THREE. WHICH CLARIFIES THE
PROCESS BY WHICH THE JUDGES
BENEFITS FROM THE JUDGE OF
RETIREMENT SYSTEM- WHICH IS BOTH
THE JUDGE RETIREMENT SYSTEM THE
JUDGE RETURNED SYSTEM TO. OUR TO
BE REDUCED WINNER BENEFITS REACH
THE INTERNAL REVENUE CODE LIMIT.
SO IT'S REALLY SOMETHING TO
RECONCILE JUDGES PENSION SYSTEM
WITH APPLICABLE LAW. CURRENT
FEDERAL TAX LAW CAPS REPUBLIC
OPPOSED TO FIND PENSION BENEFIT
TO A SPECIFIED DOLLAR AMOUNT.
FOR TWENTY TWENTY TWO IT IS
CURRENTLY TWO HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. THEREFORE AN
INDIVIDUAL CALPERS RETIREES
WHOSE PENSION BENEFIT EXCEEDS US
DOLLAR LIMIT WOULD BE CAPPED.
CALPERS IS RECENT DETERMINED
THAT THEY MUST AGGREGATE IT JUST
RETIREMENT UNDER GENEROUS AND
CHAIRS TO WITH ANY PRIOR STATE
SERVICE. THIS NEW
INTERPRETATIONS JUDGES WILL BE
MORE LIKELY EXCEED THE PENSION
INCOME CAP UNDER FEDERAL LAW-
FOR EXAMPLE OF RETIRED JUDGE
SERVE TWENTY FIVE YEARS AS A
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE. PERSONAL
TERMS NOW COMBINED WITH THEIR
JUDICIAL RETIREMENT PLUS
POTENTIALLY CAUSING JUDGES TO
HIT OR EXCEED THE FEDERAL
BENEFIT LIMIT. FOR OTHER STATE
RETIREES AFTER BENEFIT AMOUNT
EXCEEDS THE FEDERAL LIMIT THEY
MAY LOOK TO HAVE A PLACE TO
BENEFIT PLAN REDUCE THEIR AMOUNT
. CURRENTLY JUDGES UNDER THE
JAROCIN HERE TO DO NOT HAVING
REPLACEMENT BENEFIT PLAN FOR
THEIR JUDICIAL PORTION OF
AGGREGATED BENEFITS. THIS BILL
CLARIFIES THESE TWO ISSUES BY
ALLOWING JUDGES TO ACCESS HER
PLACE TO BENEFIT PLAN FOR THEIR
AGGREGATED JUDICIAL STATE
SERVICE PENSIONS AND BY
TERRIFYING THAT THE STATE
SERVICE PENSION SHOULD BE THE
PENSION AMOUNT PRODUCED FIRST.
THIS CLARIFICATION ALSO APPLIES
TO JUDGES WHO MAY WHO MAY ALSO
HAVE A PENSION FOR THE LET'S SEE
RETIREMENT SYSTEM. WHICH WOULD
SURELY BE A DIMINISH NUMBER. BY
ALLOWING JUDGES ACCESS TO OUR
BIRTHPLACE OF BENEFIT PLAN FOR
THEIR STATE SERVICE TO BE ABLE
TO RECEIVE THE BENEFITS THEY
WERE PROMISED AND CONTRIBUTE TO
OUR NOT BEING DISADVANTAGED BY
ALSO HAVE A JUDICIAL PENSION.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION
AND RECEIVED OPPOSITION. AND
HERE AT SESUAI SUPPORTERS MIKE
BLOAT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE VERY BRIEF MISTER COOLEY
OUTLINED THE ISSUE IT'S A
TECHNICAL ISSUE CONCERNING THE
INTERACTION OFTHE JUDGE'S
RETIREMENT SYSTEM FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE RETIREMENT SYSTEM
FOR THOSE FEW. PEOPLE STILL
PARTICIPATING IN THAT- WHEN YOU
HIT THIS FEDERAL LIMIT IT'S NOT
UNCOMMON TO HAVE THAT HAPPEN IF
YOU SERVED A LONG TIME FOR
EXAMPLE AS MR COOLEY SAID IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THEN A
LONG TIME ON THE BENCH. WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE- COMMITTEE CONSULTANT
AND A REPUBLICAN CONSULTANT ON
THE BILL WE THINK IT'S TECHNICAL
IN CLARIFYING AND JUST ALLOWS A
JUDGE. TO RECIEVE. THE BENEFITS
THEY WERE ENTITLED TO UNDER THE
PLAN AND WE WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER BELOW
THIS WOULD WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
THE ROOM. I NOTICES THE RUMOR
SUPPORT THIS BILL. SEEING NONE
WOULD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE FOR HOSE ON THE PHONE
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY. THE
POSITION OF THE BILL ONLY
OPERATOR. PLEASE CALL INSISTENCE
IN SUPPORT. FOR THOSE FOR AND
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. THIS TIME NO ONE HAS CUTE.
THANK YOU OPERATOR REMOVED
WITNESSES OPPOSITION ARE THERE
ANY THIS IS IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION. SIX SECONDS AND ALSO
NOT THAT WE'VE BEEN JOINED BY
MISTRAL DONALD- MESSAOUD ONE
THIS IS AN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE. ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO AND AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO WITNESSES THANK YOU
OPERATOR WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS- WOOD
MISTER COOLEY FOR CLOSING. I
REQUEST ARRIVAL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MR COLEY- THE
BILL THE MOVE BY SOME MEMBER OF
DONALD AND SECOND BY MR SUHARTO.
MEDICAID PLEASE CALL ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COOPER HI COOPER
AYE VOEPEL. CALDERON COOLEY HI
COOLEY AYE BALDONNEL. WHAT ON
EARTH I SEYARTO HI THEY ARE TO I
. THE PLACE ON CALL FOR. WHICH
COULD BILLS ON CALL MR DOLLARS
LIKE PER YOUR BILL.
SERVICE START WITH THE REMOVED
ACTUALLY THIS DONALD AB TWO FIVE
FIVE SIX. I REMEMBER FIVE. THE
DAHLE THANK YOU CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE I AM WITH AB TWO FIVE
FIVE SIX WHICH WILL ENCOURAGE
GOOD EMPLOYEE EMPLOYER RELATIONS
BY GIVING BOTH PARTIES
ADDITIONAL TIME TO REACH AN
AGREEMENT BEFORE A PUBLIC AGENCY
IMPOSES THEIR LAST BEST. AND
FINAL OFFER CURRENTLY PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS RESOLVING
UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE PRACTICES
CHARGERS AND REPRESENTATION
DISPUTES THROUGH THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD. THE
BOARD PROVIDES A COST EFFECTIVE
ALTERNATIVE FOR EMPLOYERS
EMPLOYER ORGANIZATIONS AND
EMPLOYEES TO RESOLVE THEIR
DISPUTES TO ENSURE GOOD EMPLOYEE
EMPLOYER RELATIONS THE BOARD.
THE BOARD'S PROCESS RESOLVING AN
IMPASSE INCREASING ENCOURAGES
BOTH PARTIES TO RESOLVE THE
DISPUTE AS AMICABLY AS POSSIBLE
THROUGH MEDIATION AND FACT
FINDING PROCEDURES UNDER CURRENT
LAW AFTER MEDIATION AND FACT
FINDING PARTIES ARE GIVEN ONLY
TEN DAYS TO REACT TO THOSE
FINDINGS TO RESOLVE THE
REMAINING ISSUES OF CONTROVERSY
BEFORE THE PUBLIC AGENCY CAN
IMPOSE OUR LAST BEST. AND FINAL
OFFER AB TWO FIVE FIVE SIX SIX
TO PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
DAYS FOR PARTIES TO MEET TO
DISCUSS THE FACT FINDER'S REPORT
AND WORK TOWARDS AN AGREEMENT
BEFORE THE PUBLICATION C. CAMPOS
OUR LAST BEST AND FINAL OFFER.
AND WITH YOUR WITH ME HERE TODAY
TO TESTIFY AS DOUG SUPERS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
FIRST OF SERVERS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS UP PLEASED TO BE
HERE IN SUPPORT TODAY I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DONNA FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD-AS THE AUTHOR NOTED-
THE- PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS
BOARD PROVIDES IMPORTANT PROCESS
SEES WHEN. LOCAL BARGAINING
UNITS AND THEIR EMPLOYERS CAN'T
COME TO AGREEMENT THE FACT
FINDER'S REPORT OFTEN FONG-
ASSESSES A VARIETY OF DETAILS
THAT ARE. VERY IMPORTANT AND
POTENTIALLY GETTING TO AN
AGREEMENT BEFORE THEIR- LAST
BEST AND FINAL OFFER IS IMPOSED
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO THE
FIRE SERVICES WE ARE STATUTORILY
PROHIBITED FROM OUR MEMBERS ARE
STATUTORILY PROHIBITED FROM-
STRIKING ARE PURSUING OTHER
OPTIONS TO COME TO A RESOLUTION
ON A CONTRACT AGREEMENT. SO WE
THINK MOVING IT FROM TEN TO
FIFTEEN DAYS ALLOWS FOR ROBUST
DISCUSSION BEFORE- AN EMPLOYER
MAY IMPOSE A CONTRACT SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK HER ABOUT I THANK MR SUPER
IN THIS IS IN THE ROOM SUPPORT.
SINGLE OPERATOR ANYONE IS THE
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. BUT THIS
ISN'T SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
OF THEM ZERO. AND THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
OPERATOR NEVER GONE UP WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ANYWAY THIS IS
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. SEEING
NONE OPERATOR ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE. THIS S
AN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO. I'M NOT A WITNESSES
THANK YOU OPERATOR LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. IS THERE
A MOTION. ALLMOVIE ITEM. SECOND
SECOND WELL THE FIRST POSTER
COOPER SET BY MR O'DONNELL-
METRICSKEY TAKE LOCAL POLICE.
THE MOTION IS THE PASSING BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COOPER HI COOPER
AYE VOEPEL CALDERON COOLEY. WELL
DONE I WELL DONE I THINK OUR
TELEVOTING. SEER TURNOUT VOTING
. MR DOLLAR BILLS ON CALL GREAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BUT WE
STILL NEED A- MISTER JONES
SAWYER MISTER ISRAEL MISTER
KALRA.
JONES SAWYER STEP CITIES ALL THE
WAY OKAY OKAY BUT THAT. I HEY
NAY. YEAH. THE ONE THAT EVERYONE
GETS. THE OTHER. HE JUST
RODRIGUEZ. NO LONGER YEAH. YEAH. FOR SO THAT THAT. MOST POPULAR
RULES APPLY TO SEXUAL. CAPITAL.
THAT. SO YEAH. AND MY- OKAY HI
OF THE LORD OF THE CAPITAL WE-
OKAY. SO I'VE OF OUR. CITY
COUNCIL YEAH.
FROM.
THE SERGEANTS CAN CALL OF
MISCREANTS OFFICE AND MR CALLS
OFFICE PLEASE THANK YOU.
WE KNOW THAT MR MISTER CALDERON
IS HERE.
FIVE DOLLARS AND. I'M GOING TO.
PUT IT. DID HE- NOT MOTIVATE
PEOPLE BACK. MISTER CHAIR WHAT
AUTHORS DO WE NEED. JONES SAWYER
CARILLO AND KALRA. BECAUSE OF
AYE SO WE'RE NOT GONNA WHAT WAIT
ALL DAY FOR THEM. NO FOR. ALL OF
HOMES. FOR FREE. BUT SHALL
JERSEY YES- OKAY. UNDER THE
TABLE OR.
WE HAD TO GO BACK AND. THAT WILL
BE ABLE. DON'T GIVE YOUR.
YEAH. THE FOLKS AT HOME WHAT'S
ON TV WE'VE ACTUALLY MULTIPLE
COMMITTEES GOING ON RIGHT NOW SO
MEMBERS ARE- ACTUALLY TESTIFYING
THE COMMITTEES AND ON COMMITTEE
SO- PLEASE BEAR BEAR WITH US.
SO WE'RE NOT. ABLE TO COVER. UP
THERE WE. LOTS OF. HE'S LIKE
OKAY NETWORKING ON THE FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE- A. B. TO FOUR FOUR
ONE AS WE WORK. CENTER BUILDING
YOU READY THANK YOU. THE MORNING
OF MISTER CHAIR MEMBER AB TWO
FOUR ONE WOULD REQUIRE PUBLIC
AND PLAYERS TO TRANSIT UNIONS OF
THEIR INTENTION TO PROCURE FOR
DEPLOYING NEW TECHNOLOGIES FOR
PUBLIC TRANSIT SERVE UP TRANSIT
SERVICES INCLUDING AUTONOMOUS
TRANSIT VEHICLES AT LEAST ONE
YEAR PRIOR. ADDITIONALLY
EMPLOYERS WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE THE UNION WITH THE
DETAILED ANALYSIS ON WORKER
DISPLACEMENT GAPS IN TRAINING
AND PLANS TO RETRAIN ELIGIBLE
EMPLOYEES. UPON NOTIFICATION THE
TRANSIT EMPLOYER BE REQUIRED TO
BARGAIN WITH THE UNION OVER THE
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE NEW TECHNOLOGY AS WELL AS
THE CREATION OF A TRANSITION
OVER RETRAINING PLAN FOR
AFFECTED WORKERS TO BE CLEAR
NOTHING IN THIS BILL PREVENT
CORPORATE PROHIBIT THE USE OF OR
PREVENT A TRANSIT AGENCY FROM
EXPLORING AUTONOMOUS TECHNOLOGY.
INSTEAD AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY ONE
RIGHTLY RECOGNIZES THESE
TECHNOLOGIES OFTEN COME WITH
IMPACTS ON THE EXISTING
WORKFORCE THAT SHOULD BE
REVIEWED. WELL TRANSLATE MAYES A
CO SAVINGS IN LABOR COSTS THE
STATE MUST BE VIGILANT IN
ENSURING PUBLIC SAFETY AND
MAINTAINING AN ADEQUATE
WORKFORCE. AS YOU'LL HEAR FROM
THE SUPPORTING WITNESSES WE
CAN'T FORGET THAT TRANSIT
WORKERS ALSO FULFILL NON DRIVING
RESPONSIBILITIES WHICH INCREASE
TRANS EXCESS ABILITIES PROVIDERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. AS A FORMER
MEMBER AND CHAIR THE PTA BARD
OF DIRECTORS AS WELL AS A FORMER
MEMBER OF THE CAPITAL QUARTER
JOINT POWERS AND CALTRAIN BOARDS
I UNDERSTAND THE CONSIDERATIONS
TRANSIT AGENCIES MUST TAKE ON
ONE EXPERT ON WHEN THEY EXPORT
CHANGES. TELL WE OFFER TRANSIT
THERE FROM HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION I BELIEVE WE CAN
FIND A RESOLUTION TO THEIR
CONCERNS. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL IS MATT BROUGHT ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE
BOARD OF THE AMALGAMATED TRANSIT
UNION AND THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CONSTANZO. AT LEAST GOT WHO'S A
PARA TRANSIT OPERATOR WITH
PSYCHOLOGY AND A MEMBER OF H. U.
LOCAL TWO FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU
MR CLARK BROUGHT. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MAP RIGHT HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE MAGNITUDE TRANSIT UNION
AND THE CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS WHO
ARE PROUD CO SPONSORS OF AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY ONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA. AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY ONE IS A PRETTY SIMPLE
BILL IN ESSENCE IT WILL REQUIRE
TRANSIT EMPLOYERS TO NOTIFY THE
UNION ABOUT THEIR INTENTION TO
PROCURE DEPLOY AUTONOMOUS
TRANSIT VEHICLES AND THEN MAKE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE
TECHNOLOGIES A MANDATORY SUBJECT
TO BARGAINING. I THINK IT'S
PRETTY IMPORTANT TO MENTION THAT
THE PARTIES ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
REACH A DEAL ON IMPLEMENTATION
BUT THE BILL DOES REQUIRE THEM
TO GET TOGETHER AND DISCUSS ANY
SUCH PLANS. THIS BRINGS A MUCH
NEEDED AND OFTEN OVERLOOKED
WORKER PERSPECTIVE. ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF THE AUTOMATED VEHICLES
OPERATORS MECHANICS AND OTHER
TRANSIT POLICE HAVE INVALUABLE
INSIGHT ON THE INNER WORKINGS OF
PUBLIC TRANSIT AS YOU'LL HEAR
FROM OUR NEXT WITNESS THE ROLE
OF A TRANSIT OPERATOR GOES FAR
BEYOND JUST USING A STEERING
WHEEL. JUST VERY QUICKLY WERE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE TRANSIT
IS SENSATION ADDED DRESS THEIR
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BREADTH OF
THE DEFINITION OF NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND I THINK WE'RE-
CAPABLE OF REACHING A SOFT
LANDING PLACE. WHERE THEY CAN
FEEL COMFORTABLE MOVING FORWARD
WITH. ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE L. AS LEE SCOTT
HE'S A PAIR TRANSIT ON. WE STACK
ARE. AND A MEMBER OF EIGHTY
LOCAL TO FIFTY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME DRIVE OUT THANK YOU
MISTER SCOTT. THANK YOU. MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LEE SCOTT I AM A SACK ARTIGO
PARA TRANSIT OPERATOR HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. AND HAVE BEEN FOR
TWELVE YEARS AND A PROUD MEMBER
OF EIGHTY YOU LOCAL TO FIFTY
SIX. FOR AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME. I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB
TWO TWO FOUR FOUR ONE BECAUSE IT
WILL ENSURE THAT OUR WORKERS
VOICES HEARD. RESPECTED AND
UNDERSTOOD WHEN IT COMES TO
IMPLEMENTATION OF AUTOMATED
TRANSIT VEHICLE TECHNOLOGIES. MY
JOB DUTIES THEY PARA TRANSIT
VEHICLE OPERATOR REQUIRES A
NUMBER OF TASKS. THAT MAKE
PUBLIC RANSPORTATION FOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES A SAFE SECURE
AND PLEASURABLE RIDING
EXPERIENCE. FIRST AND FOREMOST
WE ARE PROFESSIONAL IN OUR
BEHAVIOR. COURTEOUS AND TREAT
OUR PASSENGERS WITH DIGNITY AND
RESPECT. WE PERFORM OUR- WORK
ENSURING THAT OUR SAFETY THE
SAFETY OF OUR COWORKERS AND THE
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC OUR OUR
PARAMOUNT CONCERN. EACH DAY EACH
VEHICLES INSPECTED AND IS A SAFE
OPERATING CONDITION BEFORE
TRANSPORTING PASSENGERS. WE
ASSIST PASSENGERS ON AND OFF THE
VEHICLE LIFTS RAMPS ASSIST IN
THE USE OF SEATBELTS AND
WHEELCHAIR SECUREMENT. WE ESCORT
PASSENGERS ALONG ACCESSIBLE PATH
OF TRAVEL TO ENTER AND ACCESS TO
TRANSIT SYSTEM AND THEIR
DESTINATION. WE ALLOW PASSENGERS
AMPLE TIME TO BOARD AND EXIT THE
VEHICLE. WE INSURE THE A LEVEL
BOARDING AREA AND A NARROW GAP
BETWEEN THE ACCESS POINT TO THE
VEHICLE. DETERMINATE THE
WHEELCHAIR LIFTS WERE WORKING
PROPERLY AND OPERATE THEM
MANUALLY IF NECESSARY. OPERATORS
ARE ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR
EMERGENCY VEHICLE EVACUATIONS
OPERATING VEHICLE ALARMS IS
NOTHING IF NECESSARY ASSIST WITH
STOP ANNOUNCEMENTS AND DE
ESCALATE DUTIES BETWEEN DE
ESCALATE DISPUTES. BETWEEN
PASSENGERS. AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
ONE REQUIRES TRANSIT EMPLOYERS
TO NEGOTIATE WITH THE UNION OVER
THE PHASE IN. OR USE OF NEW
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE TECHNOLOGIES.
VEHICLE OPERATORS HAVE BEEN
VALUABLE INFORMATION ON HOW
PUBLIC TRANSIT WORKS HOW IT
SHOULD WORK AND MAKE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION A SAFE SECURE AND
PLEASURABLE RIDING EXPERIENCE.
OUR EMPLOYERS MUST TAKE OUR
PERSPECTIVE INTO ACCOUNT. FOR
THESE REASONS STATED I ASK YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
ONE TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANYWAY THIS IS A SUPPORT IN THE
ROOM. PLEASE COME FOR JUST TAKE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION IF ANY
THE POSITION OF THE BILL ONLY.
SAM WILKINS HELLO MISTER
CHAIRMAN HOW THE MEMBERS- WITH
THE TRANSPORT WORKERS UNION OF
AMERICA AND WE STAND IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO FOUR FOUR ONE THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS LIVING COSTS THAT WITH
SMART TRANSPORTATION DIVISION
CALIFORNIA STATES LET IT
LEGISLATIVE BOARD IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS AGENDA SO MAINLY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CINNAMINSON SUPPORT- OPERATOR ON
THE PHONE ANYWAY THIS IS IN
SUPPORT. ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. FIND SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MATT KREMIN SHALL BE
HAPPY CALIFORNIA NEVADA
CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND THERE ARE NO
OTHER LINES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
OPERATOR. NOW WE'RE GOING TO
LOSE IT- BUT THIS IS AN
OPPOSITION. ANYONE IS OPPOSITION
OF THE ROOM. NOT IN OPPOSITION
MISTER CHAIR- MATT ROBINSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION WERE SERVING IN IN
BETWEEN POSITION RIGHT NOW- I
JUST WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA- MISTER BROAD AFTER
THE REMARKS ABOUT THE
COLLABORATION GOING FORWARD TO
MISTER BOLTON FOR WORKING IN
SOME OF MY COMMENTS LATE INTO
HIS ANALYSIS I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT- THE ANALYSIS LAYS IT OUT
REALLY WELL- THE WAY THE BILL
CURRENTLY IS LAID OUT IT'S
EXTREMELY BROAD I THINK IT'S
GOING TO LEAD OUR MEMBER.
AGENCIES TO A LOT OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHEN THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
TRIGGER SOME OF THESE PROCESSES-
IT COULD LEAD TO YOU KNOW MORE
CUMBERSOME- SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES
FOR TECHNOLOGY THAT WE MAY
CONSIDER TO BE VERY SIMPLE LIKE
WE NEED TO GET ALL OF OUR
EMPLOYEES NEW COMPUTERS IN THEIR
OFFICES IN OUR OPINION THAT
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE COVERED
BY THE BILL. WE ARE BRINGING
ZERO EMISSION BUSES ONLINE THAT
MAY NOT OPERATE CURRENTLY ON
CERTAIN SYSTEMS AND THAT'S A NEW
TECHNOLOGY BUT IT REALLY DOESN'T
HAVE WILL DO DRIVER TRAINING AND
THINGS LIKE THAT ON THE VEHICLES
AND ON THE MAINTENANCE SIDE OF
IT BUT IT'S NOT I'D WORKER
DISPLACEMENT ISSUE FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE SO I THINK MOVING
FORWARD BUT WE WOULD ASK IS-
REALLY TO SIT DOWN WITH THE
PROPONENTS OF THE BILL. TO HONE
IN ON THE TECHNOLOGY THAT THAT
EXIST TODAY OR THAT MAY EXIST IN
THE VERY NEAR FUTURE THAT IS
GIVING THE UNIONS THE CONCERNS-
THAT BROUGHT THE BILL FORWARD
AND THEN HOPEFULLY REFINE IT TO
FOCUS ON THOSE TECHNOLOGIES AND
SO WITH THAT I THANK. YOU FOR
THE TIME MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU. SONORA IS NOT. IN ROOM-
OPERATOR. THE WITNESSES
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE. IF
THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO AND THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES TO BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
THEIR MOTION. A SECOND. MISTER
KALRA THE WITH MY CLOTHES
STARTED OUT FROM ABOUT OKAY- THE
BILL'S BEEN IN MOTION BY BELIEVE
ME. SECOND AYE MR O'DONNELL-
LOCAL POLICE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS COOPER HI COOPER AYE VOEPEL
CALDERON COOLEY O'DONNELL. BY
ARE DONE ALL I SEE ARE TO HAVE A
CERTAIN ABILITY. OKAY RURAL BACK
TO THANK YOU THINK JUST YOUR
BILL OF ALL. WELL THAT'S NOT A
NUMBER ONE- AB TWO ZERO FOUR
FIVE MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I PRESENT
TO YOU AB TWENTY FORTY FIVE
CLASS BY POSITIONS HIRING
FLEXIBILITY ACT SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE TO CALIFORNIA LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES HAVE USED THE
ROLE OF THREE RANKS TO HIRE
CANDIDATES BASED ON DEPLOYMENT
EXAMINATION SCORES CLASS BY
POSITIONS ARE THOSE THAT DO NOT
REQUIRE CREDENTIALS SUCH AS
MAINTENANCE AND CUSTODIAL STAFF
BUS DRIVERS AND CAFETERIA STAFF.
THE RULE OF THREE RANKS BROWN'S
EACH CANDIDATE SCORE FROM THE
EXAMINATION PROCESS TO THE
NEAREST PERCENTAGE POINT AND
THEN RANKS OF SCORES BY ONE
PERCENTAGE POINT THIS MEANS ONLY
THE TOP THREE SCORES ELIGIBLE
FOR POTENTIAL EMPLOYMENT
LIMITING THE POOL OF CANDIDATES
COULD BE CONSIDERED. THE CURRENT
SYSTEM. L. SIGNAL IS DEAD AN
APPLICANT WHO MAY BE BETTER
SUITED OVERALL FOR A PARTICULAR
JOB MAY COME FROM A
SOCIOECONOMIC BACKGROUND THAT
HAS LED THEM TO LESS ADAPT ITS
STANDARDIZED TESTS AND AS A
RESULT WHICH INADVERTENTLY
LOCKED IM OUT OF. FROM A JOB
OPPORTUNITY WELL INTENDED BIRD
THAT NEPOTISM OR BIAS IN HIRING
TO ROUTE THREE RANKS HAS ITS OWN
SET OF CHALLENGES. THE 1%
DISTINCTION BETWEEN RANKS IS SO
NARROW THAT IT LIMITS THE
ABILITY FOR HIRING COMMITTEES TO
CONSIDER WELL QUALIFIED OUT
APPLICANTS. WHO MAY EXCEL IN
OTHER JOB RELATED FACTORS IN
SECURE HIGH TEST SCORES BUT DO
NOT LAND WITHIN THE TOP THREE
RANKS. AS SUCH AB TWENTY FORTY
FIVE WILL ALLOW L. A. TO OPT
INTO A BANDING SYSTEM THAT WOULD
INSTEAD GROUP CANDIDATES BY 6%
INTERVALS IN INCREASED THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT CAN BE
CONSIDERED FOR HIRING TO FIVE
CANDIDATES. IF ENACTED THIS BILL
WILL HELP COMBAT THE LACK OF
ADEQUATE REPRESENT. HAVE
ADEQUATE REPRESENTATION HELP
ALLEVIATE STAFF SHORTAGES THAT
ARE IMPACTED THAT IMPACT
EDUCATION SYSTEM THIS BILL WILL
HELP CALIFORNIA TAKE ANOTHER
STEP TOWARDS TRUE EDUCATION.
EQUITY JOINING ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT IS UP MICHAEL HENRY WITH
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY PERSONNEL
COMMISSION LEKO AS WELL AS RANDY
PEREZ WITH THE MATTEO COUNTY
OFFICE. OF EDUCATION AND- GARCIA
GONNA CALL YES. I HOPE SO THEN
PUT ON A RED ON THE PHONE OR NOT
. OPERATE WE HAVE OUR WOULD. I'M
HERE TO YEAH. AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MIKE HENRY. I AM A
PERSONNEL COMMISSIONER FOR THE
LOS ANGELES. COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION INFORMALLY KNOWN AS
LAKE ALL. AND AS AN ORGANISATION
WE ARE IN TOTAL TOTAL SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY FORTY FIVE. THIS
LEGISLATION IS LONG OVERDUE AND
WILL SERVE TO BENEFIT EMPLOYEES
MANAGEMENT AND IT THE
ADMINISTRATION. WELL I'M
CURRENTLY EIGHT PERSONNEL
COMMISSIONER WITH LATE GOAL FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS MY TESTIMONY
TODAY WILL CENTER AROUND MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH BANDING
DOING MY THIRTY TWO YEAR CAREER
WITH LOS ANGELES COUNTY. WHERE I
SERVED IN A VARIETY OF POSITIONS
FROM AN INITIAL INTERNSHIP. TO
DEPARTMENT HEAD OF THE COUNTY
HUMAN RESOURCE DEPARTMENT I
SERVED AS THE CURRENT COUNTY
PERSONNEL DIRECTOR FOR ABOUT
FOURTEEN YEARS AND RETIRED FROM
THAT POSITION IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE. THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
USE BANDING STARTING IN THE
EARLY EIGHTIES AROUND THE SAME
TIME THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
INSTITUTED THIS PROCESS AS A
MEANS OF MEANS OF GIVING THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND MANAGERS MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN THE HIRING
PROCESS. DURING MY TENURE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOTH EMPLOYEES
AND MANAGEMENT AND BRACED THIS
PROCESS WHICH CONTINUES TO THIS
DAY. HI I PERSONALLY DO I MIGHT
THIRTY TWO YEAR CAREER WITH THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
PARTICIPATED AS A CANDIDATE IN
MANY EXAMS UNDER BANDY AND
COMPARED TO THE RULE OF THREE
BANDING WAS MORE EFFICIENT AND
FAIR- SOME OF THE BENEFITS ARE A
LARGER SELECTION WHO OF
CANDIDATES TO BE INTERVIEWED-
THEN THE RULE OF THREE. LESS
RESTRICTIVE IN THE RULE OF
THREE. AND OVER TIME IT APPEARS
THAT BY A BY PRODUCT OF BANNING
IS GREATER DIVERSE CITY. THIS
BILL DOES NOT MANDATE BANDYING
AND THEREFORE ALLOWS DISTRICTS
TO DECIDE WHETHER THEY FEEL IT
IS RIGHT FOR THE ORGANIZATION- I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
HOPE THAT- YOU ALL SUPPORT. BILL. TWENTY FORTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NET WITNESS. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS RANDY EREZ I'M I'M I'M
WITH THE SAN MATEO COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION I THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FORTY FIVE
WITH THE CURRENT STAFFING
SHORTAGES SPEAKING PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT THE TIME IS NOW FOR A
BILL LIKE AB TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
THE ROLE OF THREE RANKS
ARTICULATED IN THE PRESENCE OF
THE LEGISLATION THE TOP DOWN
SELECTION MODEL THAT IS ON ONE
HAND LIMITING IN A NUMBER OF
QUALIFIED CANDIDATES CONSIDERED
HIGHER AND ON ANOTHER IS PRONE
TO HAVE ADVERSE IMPACT ON PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND PEOPLE AND PROTECT
CLASSES. THE UNIFORM GUIDELINES
ON EMPLOYEE SELECTION PROCEDURES
STRONGLY EMPATHIZED THAT PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS SET FOR ADVERSE IMPACT
IN THEIR TESTING AND SELECTION
PROCEDURES. BUT THE NAY VERY
NATURE OF EDUCATION- CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION CODE SECTION FOUR FIVE
TWO SEVEN TO. MAKE IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR PERSONAL
COMMISSION OPTED TO MITIGATE
ADVERSE IMPACT. WE HAVE THE DATA
AND WE CAN SEE WHERE THERE IS
THE POSSIBILITY FOR ADVERSE
IMPACT. BUT THE PRESENT SELECTED
JUST THE PROJECT WILL CHALLENGES
IN ADDRESSING THE ISSUE. AB
TWENTY FORTY FIVE WOULD HELP
BRIDGE NOT COMMISSION OPTED. TO
MAKE REAL MEANINGFUL CHANGE IN
MITIGATING ADVERSE IMPACT. OUR
EXAMINATION IS NOT DETERMINISTIC
IT'S PROBABLY STICK IN OTHER
WORDS ARE DOWN DO NOT FULLY
GUARANTEE EMPLOYMENT SUCCESS.
THERE IS A PROBABILITY THAT ARE
DOWN TO PREDICT EMPLOYMENT
EMPLOYMENT SIX SAT BUT TO WHAT
DEGREE THAT DEPEND ON VARIOUS
FACTORS. THE SMALL DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN PASSPORT MAY NOT MAY NOT
TRANSLATE INTO MEANINGFUL
DIFFERENCES IN EXPECTED JOB
PERFORMANCE. WE HAVE TO HAVE A
SYSTEM THAT CONTROL FOR ERROR
AND OUR QUALIFICATION PROCESS.
IT BANJA METHOD THAT THAT LIKE
THAT ARTICULATED IN AB TWENTY
FORTY FIVE WOULD GIVE IT THE
ABILITY TO CONTROL PRAYER. AB
TWENTY FORTY FIVE WOULD ALLOW
FOR A GREATER NUMBER OF
QUALIFIED CANDIDATES TO MOVE TO
THE SELECTION PROCESS. AND A
GREATER NUMBER OF CANDIDATES
WOULD INEVITABLY ALLOW FOR A
MORE DIVERSIFIED AND INCLUSIVE
CANDIDATE POOL FOR HIGHER. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND FOR
CONSIDERING AB TWENTY FORTY FIVE
. THANK YOU MESSIN WITH DOING
THIS IS A SUPPORT IN THE ROOM.
ANYONE IS A SPORT. WE'LL DO ON
WHAT IS ON THE PHONE OPERATOR IN
THIS IS A SUPPORT ON THE PHONE.
THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. FIND EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. IT'S REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND SPONSORS AB TWENTY
FORTY FIVE I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ON FIRE FOR
OFFERING THE BILL AND- I VOTE
THANK YOU MEMBERS HAVE A GREAT
DAY THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES HI THIS
IS KENNETH COTTO I'M WITH THE
LONG BEACH UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT PERSONNEL COMMISSION-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
CONSIDERATION WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. UNLINED FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ANDREA BALL ON BEHALF OF
THE LONG BEACH UNIFIED
DISTRICT BY THE DISTRICT HASN'T
TAKEN A FORMAL POSITION WE'D
LIKE TO SEE THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
THE AUTHOR THE PHAM THIRDS ON
THE COMMITTEE ANYTHING THAT CAN
IMPROVE THE ELECTION PROCESS. TO
ALLOW US TO FILL VACANCIES AND
ESTABLISH A MORE DIVERSE
WORKFORCE REFLECTIVE OF LONG
BEACH UNIFIED COMMUNITY IT'S
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED. THANK YOU
. AND ARE NOT MARKED WITNESSES.
THANK YOU OPERATOR NOW WE'RE
GOING TO DO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANYONE IS NOT
POSITION IN THEIR ROOM. YOUR
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CASSIE MANZINI
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION I
WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE
TO THE AUTHOR AND STAFF FOR
WORKING ON US. I WITH US ON
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS THE NEXT COMMITTEE
THANK YOU. SO YOU'RE NOT
OPPOSITION. OPPOSITE OKAY SO
HEAR ME WILL DIFFERENT. OKAY
THING NO MORE WITNESSES
OPPOSITION THE ROOM- WILL BE TO
THE PHONE OPERATOR ANYONE IS IN
OPPOSITION. IF THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND THERE
ARE NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS IS. SURE MISSES THE
ARCO THANK YOU MISTER JONES
SAWYER THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS- BRINGING THE L. E. A. INTO
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY- I'VE
SEEN BOTH THESE OVER THE PAST
THIRTY YEARS- AND BANDING
CERTAINLY IS A MORE PREFERABLE
METHOD. OF BEING ABLE TO SELECT
EMPLOYEES THAT- PRETTY MUCH
EQUALLY QUALIFIED. AND SO IT
GIVES A LOT MORE- LATITUDE AND
TO THE POWERS TO BE TO SELECT
EMPLOYEES BASED ON THEIR
ORGANIZATION NEEDS SO I'LL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY THANK
YOU MISS A LOT OF THE MOTION.
THAT IS A MOTION OH WELL OKAY
THANK. MISTER O'DONNELL. K- THE
FIRST WAS- MADAM CLERK YOU TAKE
ROLE PLEASE THE MOVE IS THE
PERSON BE TO THE COMMITTEE
HIGHER. COOPER HI. COOPER I
VOEPEL CALDERON COOLEY O'DONNELL
I O'DONNELL I TWO NOW JUST
GETTING. HI THERE. THE BILL HAS
THREE VOTES PHONE CALL YOUR BILL
LOCAL MESSAGES SAWYER THANK YOU
THAT'S REMOVED I NUMBER ARE LESS
ITEM I'M TWO A. B. FOUR- SOME
KHALEEL.
RECEIVE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I AM PROUD 2% OF THE BILL TWO
FOUR THIRTEEN. WHICH WOULD ALLOW
CLASSIFY SIR CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE
SCHOOL OR COMMUNITY COLLEGE THE
TRUMP PLEASED TO REMAIN IN. PAID
STATUS WHILE A PERSONAL PERSONAL
INVESTIGATION APPEAL IS ONGOING
IF THERE IS NO CLEAR EVIDENCE OF
WHAT IS ALLEGE AND IT DOESN'T
CONFLICT WITH AN EXISTING
COLLECTIVE. BARGAINING AGREEMENT
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ARE.
BUS DRIVERS CUSTODIANS
ELECTRICAL WORKERS AND
MAINTENANCE STAFF THAT WORK FOR
CALIFORNIA. SCHOOLS DISTRICTS
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
A CERTIFICATE- A CERTIFIED
TEACHING STAFF REMAINED IN PAID
STATUS WHILE APPEALING N
INVESTIGATION AND THIS ALLOWS
THEM TO FULLY EXERCISE THEIR DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS. HOWEVER
CLASSIFIED STAFF GENERALLY HAVE
THEIR PAY SUSPENDED AND THIS
MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO PRESENT ALL THE FACTS IN THE
CASE IT'S MOST MAKE NEAR MINIMUM
WAGE. AND CAN AFFORD TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES WHILE THE BILL'S
PILOT MANY CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
HAVE AN ARBITRATION PROCESS AND
THEIR CBA AND OUR INTENT IS TO
RESPECT THAT PROCESS. RATHER IT
WILL GOVERN CASES WHERE THE
APPEAL IS DIRECTLY TO THE
GOVERNING BOARD AND THOSE
APPEALS TYPICALLY LAST ONLY JUST
A FEW WEEKS AT POST TO TESTIFY
OVER THE PHONE IS TRISTEN BROWN
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR C. THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS. MISTER BROWN. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY-
TRISTEN BROWN WHAT'S HERE SHE
UNION OF EDUCATORS ACROSS BY
PROFESSIONALS WE ARE THE SPONSOR
OF THIS. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR THIRTEEN. ECHOING THE
COMMENTS OF HIS CARDIO- WE ARE
HERE TO- I THINK. REALLY SECURE
THE RIGHT THAT ALREADY EXISTS
FOR CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES-
AFTER A SCHOOL EMPLOYEE. IS
REPRIMANDED FOR DISCIPLINES-
AFTER SKELLY HEARING WHICH IS A
OF THE BASELINE DUE PROCESS
RIGHT THEY ALL HAVE. THERE IS AN
OPTION IN CURRENT LAW TO APPEAL
THE DECISION OF THE HEARING
OFFICER AND GO TO THE PEOPLE
SCHOOL BOARD. PARTIALLY DURING
THAT PERIOD OF TIME- MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS ARE NOT. I TO BROUGH IN
STAFF. AND BEING VERY LOW WAGE
WORKER ACROSS THE STATE. EIGHT
RIGHT THAT YOU CAN AFFORD TO
EXERCISE NO RIGHT YOU HAPPEN ALL
AND SO WERE- SPONSORING THIS
BILL TO GIVE A LITTLE BIT OF
CUSHION- FORTY CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES THAT WOULD APPEAL THE
DECISION RIGHT TO THE SCHOOL
BOARD- THAT USUALLY OCCURS AT
THE NEXT MEETING OR PERHAPS THE
SUBSEQUENT IT'S A VERY QUICK
TURNAROUND OFTENTIMES. AND WE'RE
PUTTING CAPS ON THE AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT FOLKS WOULD BE-
EXERCISING THEIR RIGHTS IN THE
B. C. B. FOR A NEUTRAL THIRD
PARTY ARBITER- DOES CAN LAST A
LITTLE BIT LONGER WITHOUT IT
WOULD BE REASONABLE. TO LIMIT
THE TIME THERE BUT ABOVE ALL
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE PROTECTING
THOSE WHO HAVE VALID CONCERNS
AND HAVE INCLUDED A LINK WHICH
HERE TO MAKE SURE THAT IF THERE
IS CLEAR AND CONVINCING EVIDENCE
OF CRIMINAL MISCONDUCT- THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WOULD NOT REMAIN IN
PAID STATUS. BECAUSE IT WOULD BE
SO CLEAR AND CONVINCING OF THE
OCCURRENCE SO REVEREND EITHER
TODAY PER VIEW AND THE REST OF
THE COMMITTEE TO HELP SECURE THE
RIGHT OF OUR CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES TO BE ABLE TO ACCEPT
THEIR APPELLATE RIGHTS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU MISTER
BROWN AND THAT'S REMOVED
WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT IN THE
ROOM. EVANESCENCE BORTON ROOM-
SAID YOUR NAME AND POSITION OF
THE ONLY PLEASE MISTER CHAIRMAN
MAP BROUGHT AFTER THE TEAMSTERS
WITH LATE SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS- JENNIFER MAINLY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SEEN THE MORE WITNESSES REMOVED
WITNESSES OUGHT SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE OPERATOR. IF THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND ARE
NO WITNESSES THANK YOU OPERATOR
NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ANYWAY
THIS IS OPPOSITION OF THE ROOM-
SIGNAL MOVED THE PHONE OPERATOR
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE PLEASE. THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO AND THERE
ARE NO WITNESSES THANK YOU-
CONDUCT THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS- MOTION. SECOND GIVE
GOT A FIRST IN A SECOND- THIS
CARILLO IN THE CLOSING STATEMENT
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS
BILL CREATES PARITY FOR
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES AND
PERSONNEL AND EDUCATION SCHOOL
PROTECTING EXISTING AGREEMENTS
WITH AN EXCEPTION FOR INSTANCES
WHERE THERE IS CLEAR EVIDENCE OF
WRONGDOING EVERYONE WHO KEEPS
OUR SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES
COLLEGES A SAFE DESERVES TO BE
TREATED FAIRLY ON THE JOB AND I-
THIS BILL HAS NOT POSITION AS
MENTIONED I. RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE AND THANK
OUR SPONSOR THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS FOR THEIR
PARTNERSHIP AND THE JUST THE- A
MOMENT- TO JUST SAY THANK YOU TO
YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS MAY BE THE
LAST TIME THAT I PERCENT AND
THIS COMMITTEE AND TO SEE U. S.
TURN TO SPREE SHE YOUR SERVICE
TO OUR STATE THANK YOU. NANAKULI
REQUESTS AND I DON'T THINK SO
MUCH- BUILD THE MOVE- FOR SINCE
I. MEDICINE WILL CALL POLICE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND BE RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON HIGHER
EDUCATION. COOPER HI. COOPER I
VOEPEL. HI VOEPEL I CALL THAT ON
CALDERON I COOLEY. COOLEY I.
O'DONNELL I TWO. CIERTA. THAT
BILL IS OUT SIX WEEKS. FIVE TWO.
HEY THAT BILLS UP TO ONE THANK
YOU- SO WE WILL GO BACK INTO THE
ADAM NOW. WELL SECRETARY SOLD DO
A- I REMEMBER ONE. AB TWO FORTY
FIVE. THE CURRENT IS THREE TO
ZERO VOEPEL I HOPE I CALL THE-
CALDERON I. COOLEY I HAVE BILLS
SIXTY ONE DOLLAR THREE AB. TWO
FOUR FOUR ONE. THE CURRENT TO
DESERVE VOEPEL NO VOEPEL NOW
BECAUSE THEY DON'T. GOVERNOR I
COOLEY COOLEY I THOUGHT BILL IS
OUT FOUR TO ONE THANK YOU A
NUMBER FOR A BI FOURTH. THREE
CURRENT VOTERS FORTY VOTE. THE
WARM BY. VOEPEL I A LITTLE. GIRL
THAT ITEM BILL WITHOUT SUCCESS
HERE THANK YOU CAN LEFT IN THE
LEAST OF FIVE A. B. TWO FIVE
FIVE SIX THE KERR VOTERS TO DO.
VOEPEL HI VOEPEL I ALLEN ON.
OTHER I THE BILL WITHOUT. TWO
ZERO.
THANK YOU THAT BILLS UP BY TWO
ZERO NINE THANK YOU THANKS FOR
WORK FOR COMING BACK HAVE A
GREAT DAY THIS MEETINGS
ADJOURNED. I DON'T. THINK.